hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Beowulf episode for video just
give up for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet the biggest storyline
this week was wrapping up the council
votes storyline and spinning it into the
goreck muir storyline I'm considering
that the a story this week because in
order for Rita to win the council vote
she has to fulfill Hrothgar's promise to
give them weapons and in surprise
surprise gets lien married to one of
their princesses to bind their peoples
together mostly you probably know from
watching any kind of historical drama
that that was actually a pretty common
practice Rita is happy to do it it was
probably the reason that she married
Hrothgar in the first place to bind
their two villages together but then of
course lien turns his head and is like
wait what say what now what you do
everything's fine of course until Slean
gets the bright idea to blame the
Skinshifter plot on rate and his men now
you have to remember that his village is
where most of the Warriors come from so
if the war egg which they teased in this
episode become a big problem then
slean's doing a very excellent job of
destabilizing his village
now of course Abra can has promised him
that he can make him a saint eventually
like oh I could I could totally make
that happen for you if I were to leave
the council but if the warig were to
charge on a rot and they didn't have the
Warriors they needed there wouldn't be
any village to be Thane of which is kind
of what happened to Gore ex-people the
mirror they say about 20 years ago they
were almost wiped out which is actually
the area we find where Alvina is from so
she's ordered to tag along when they
take the weapons so it seems simple
enough take the weapons bring back a
bride everything's good and if it wasn't
clear is part of the resolution to the
council votes storyline Rita compels
Beowulf to become the new constable of
the village and while he's happy to help
nobody wants him around and he doesn't
necessarily want to stick around that
badly but he does feel a certain loyalty
to his village and there's still the
mystery of how Hrothgar died there's
still just a lot of unanswered questions
so he wants to stick around to try and
find out what the hell's going on that's
why it was so funny when rate was
walking past him at the beginning of the
episode and he's like hey what are you
still doing here
you should you should be gone this is
all over now and Beowulf's like still
got a mystery out there I gotta
kill frontier justice hell yeah the bad
part about being a person of authority
is that you're bound by the laws of your
village which actually Rita now is
trying to change let's call that the B
storyline I think they'll use that as a
catalyst for Abra kin to turn against
Rita openly just open conflict how dare
you try to change the laws how dare you
try to make us all do this
all these people in the show are from
places that are steeped in tradition and
if there's anything we know that people
steeped in tradition really love its
rapid and sudden change so the council
vote is over Beowulf is on his way going
to fulfill the promise everything seems
fine but really what's going on is that
the alliance that binds the council is
slowly destabilizing more and more you
have half the council that hates Rita
now there's probably going to buying and
comment Alliance the other half is
depending on Beowulf to fulfill this
promise
so really the match has already been lit
it's gonna blow up in everyone's faces
that's one of the most fun things when
you see everyone teetering on the edge
like oh all you have to do is this one
thing and it will go perfectly so of
course nothing goes to plan and really
this is where the episode starts to get
exciting when Beowulf breca gorrik
Elvina and then vishka tag along run
into the war egg fish could kind of
reminded me of Bilbo Baggins in The
Hobbit as she's like running out of town
I'm going on an adventure and we all
know what's the first thing you do when
you're on an adventure and you find a
mysterious burial site you disturb it
the really cool thing about this Warwick
storyline is that you actually learned
that they do have a culture they have
their own language there's a hierarchy
but it seems like they're led by their
shaman their shaman is the leader of
that community so in order to throw them
off Beowulf takes back what vishka took
and then sets their burial site on fire
no way that's not gonna come back to
bite them in the ass yeah it's awesome
seeing them finally get to the island
but you have to feel bad for that
woodsman and his family he's dead now
they have to go live somewhere else
there's no way that cabins gonna be safe
anymore but if you've seen the teaser
for episode 5 you know this is really
just the tipping point like the
Warwick's starting to mass is really the
beginning of things really going crazy
on the show so be sure to watch this
weekend if you like sand worms and pitch
battle that's definitely my favorite
aspect of the show but let me know in
the comments what was your guy's
favorite moment from the episode and how
quickly do you think that things will
actually turn to open battle like how
long will the Alliance last with Rita
trying to change everything half the
council already wanting to get rid of
her and their most powerful warrior
stuck with a lot of their weapons very
far away in actually sidebar a lot of
you have picked up on it but Grendel
here has been following Alvina around a
lot of you have thought that she might
be his mother which I do really like
that idea but it certainly doesn't
explain a lot because she doesn't look
that old
and he looks relatively full-grown so
there's still a whole
explained that we have to do I cannot
wait for Beowulf to find out about her
special friend like oh the creature that
we tried to kill in that cave that one
time he's your special friend why didn't
you tell us WTF so the first four
episodes this is definitely my favorite
so far
episode 5 is gonna air Saturday on the
Esquire network at 10/9 central and they
have been posting behind-the-scenes
stuff with the actors on their website
that's Esquire tv.com slash Beowulf so
while you guys wait for my next video
just in case you haven't seen it you can
click here for my episode 3 video and
you can click here for my episode 2
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight